What I like about IMAX is because
it's taking up your entire field of view
you're actually choosing what to look at
so you could really zero in on an aspect
of the image that you're curious about
Everything the light touches, is our kingdom
There's a tremendous amount of
detail that's gone into this
Everything has to be constructed by artists and
seeing it in the large format
you could really see it vividly and all the
nuances that you see every single hair
you see every leaf
because the entire film
is set in either caves or exteriors
so much of the experience is feeling the
environment around you and with the
sound design also associated with IMAX
you feel immersed in that
Run away Simba and never return
A big part of why people want to go to the movies now
is to is to have that
immersive experience the more of a
theatrical beautiful immersive
experience you have the more it entices
people to come out and enjoy it in that
traditional theater setting
You have to take your place as king
The hard part
was the thing that we did that was new
that hadn't been done before which is
our style of virtual filmmaking where we
took the entire digital environment and
the animated digital characters and put
it into essentially a virtual reality
multiplayer game we were able to have
the entire crew come into a digital set
and scout it and film it as though they
were on a real location so if you came
and visited us you would see what looks
like a functioning live-action film set
it starts to inherit the aesthetic of a
live-action production just the scale
and quality of the experience
He had a really bold vision for the movie
especially for Timon and Pumbaa which is
the keep our scenes very natural feeling
and very conversational and organic
within this big spectacle and and I
think he did a great job
a lot of it is the translation of the performances
through the interpretation of the
animators using the body language or the
emotional language of each species
It's pretty epic just on a traditional screen
I mean it's shot and designed so
beautifully than an IMAX that's gonna be
pretty intense
yeah we'll be funnier in IMAX
We're here
Oh everyone calm down
we're here